the following is a conversation with
Robert F Kennedy Jr candidate for the
president of the United States running
as a Democrat Robert is an activist
lawyer and author who has challenged
some of the world's most powerful
corporations seeking to hold them
accountable for the harm they may cause
I love science and engineering these two
Pursuits are to me the most beautiful
and Powerful in the history of human
civilization science is our journey our
fight for uncovering the laws of nature
and leveraging them to understand the
universe and to lessen the amount of
suffering in the world
some of the greatest human beings I've
ever met including most of my good
friends are scientists and Engineers
again I love science
but science cannot flourish without
epistemic humility without debate both
in the pages of academic journals and in
the Public Square in good faith
long-form conversations agree or
disagree I believe Robert's voice should
be part of the debate to call him a
conspiracy theorist and arrogantly
dismiss everything he says without
addressing it diminishes The public's
trust in the scientific process
at the same time dogmatic skepticism of
all scientific output on controversial
topics like the pandemic is equally if
not more dishonest and destructive
I recommend that people read and listen
to Robert F Kennedy Jr
his arguments and his ideas
but I also recommend as I say in this
conversation that people read and listen
to Vincent racquanelo from this week in
virology Dan Wilson from debunk the funk
and the Twitter and books of Paul offit
Eric tople and others who are outspoken
in their disagreement with Robert
it is disagreement not Conformity that
bends the long Arc of humanity toward
truth and wisdom
in this process of this agreement
everybody has a lesson to teach you but
we must have the humility to hear it and
to learn from it